قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
جوتيريش انه تشاور مع المفوض العام
للاونروا فيليب لازاريني بتعيين مجموعه
مراجعه مستقله لتقييم ما اذا كانت الوكاله
تبذل ما في وسعها لضمان الحيادي والرد على
مزعم الانتهاكات الجزيمه عند ارتكابها
وقال المتحدث باسم الامين العام ستيفن
دوجريك ان وزيره خارجيه فرنسا السابقه
كاترين كولونا ستقود المراجعه ومن المتوقع
ان يكتمل التق نهائي بحلول ابريل من العام
الجاري يقول الامين العام ان هذه
الاتهامات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه الاونروا
وهي اكبر منظمه تابعه للامم المتحده في
المنطقه في طروف صعبه للغايه وذلك لتقديم
المساعده المنقذه للحياه لمليوني شخص في
قطاع غزه والذين يعتمدون عليها للبقاء على
قيد الحياه وسط واحده من اكبر الازمات
الانسانيه واكثرها تع في العالم وستتم هذه
المراجعه الخارجيه المستقله بالتوازي مع
التحقيق الذي يجريه حاليا مكتب الامم
المتحده لخدمات الرقابه الداخليه في مزاعم
تورط 12 من موظفي الاونروا في هجمات
السابع من اكتوبر وسيكون تعاون السلطات
الاسرائيليه التي اطلقت هذه الادعاءات
حاسما لنجاح
التحقيق